and welcome here to the hot set
Microsoft researchers bill belofsky and
Robbie Pangaea here with me in studio
professor david patterson in the
university of california berkeley
joining us via skype he's online just
like many of you gentlemen you have made
a rather startling prediction namely
that big data will lead to cures for the
big c for cancer and that is a bold
assertion let's jump right in and I know
none of your medical doctors but i trust
that one of you is willing to bmv for a
day and explain why cancer has been so
difficult to cure Robbie you can lead
things off sure so one of the basically
cancer is fundamentally a genomic
disease and what happens is you
accumulate us the wrong set of mutations
in the cell and they break down certain
processes in the cell that caused it to
replicate uncontrollably and the one of
the reasons it's been difficult is
essentially each cancer is unique
genomically if you look at the detail
genomic changes involved and you can
compare which we can now do the tumor to
the normal cells even in what seems to
be the same kind of cancer let's say ten
different cases or a hundred different
cases of breast cancer the individual
mutations tend to be fairly different
and so that's one piece of the problem
which is that we now need to you know
look at a lot of data to be able to
figure out what are the sort of
fundamental deeper causes of that cancer
and then the other is that there are
multiple causes at the same time because
there are different pieces there veriton
there are many different things that
your body uses to keep cells from
propagating uncontrollably and so you
may need to apply several different
therapies or one therapy might attack
one piece you need a different therapy
for some other piece that's broken yeah
you mentioned the genomic view there
when you hear about cancers you know
it's usually described as disease of a
certain part of the body you know we
hear lung cancer brain cancer breast
cancer so on so talk to me a little bit
more about how this traditional view of
cancers differs from the genomic view of
cancer so that's one of the things
there's a project that
working with in called the Cancer Genome
Atlas which is collecting together data
from you know 500 breast cancer cases
500 prostate cancer cases and so on and
then what we're starting to do is look
across that entire data set and look at
what are the common molecular signatures
that are that are common across these
different kinds of cancers so we're
starting to find that you know there
might be a drug if we actually look at
the gene the genomic changes involved in
a particular case of lung cancer it
might actually be treatable by drug that
was initially used for skin cancer for
example because they are chiral
molecular mechanism underlying it is the
same Wow bill I mean all of us know
somebody who has battled cancer or as
battling cancer it seems like a lot of
the the therapies and the treatments are
is a rough as the cancer itself talk
about how the genomic approach that
therapy is going to change this so if
you look at traditional chemotherapy
cannon cancer treatments essentially
what they did was to look for drugs that
kill cancer cells a little bit faster
than they killed normal cells and this
is much trickier to do with cancer than
it is say with bacterial infections
because cancer cells are slightly
modified versions of your own cells and
the problem with those drugs of course
is that they make you really sick so
they go off and kill fast growing and
often what they do is target cells that
grow quickly because cancer cells always
grow quickly and so you lose your hair
you lose the lining of your stomach and
you have horrible nausea then the new
rational medicine approaches to cancer
look at the particular cancer they have
like Robbie was saying you can actually
look at the mutations in your personal
cancer and target something that's
unique about your cancer rather than
about all fast-growing cells and as a
result you can get a era p that's both
more destructive to the cancer cells and
less destructive to the healthy cells so
you wind up during the cancer without
killing the patient a great analogy for
this as if you look back to the 19th
century I read a great book about
Meriwether Lewis Lewis and Clark Lewis
and he had malaria and it turned out at
the time the treatment for malaria
mercury they gave you the thing that you
think of as horrible poison don't ever
touch it don't ever touch it they
intentionally took mercury because
mercury kills Plasmodium the the
parasite that causes malaria a little
bit faster than it makes you insane huh
and so you know when the choice was
dying of malaria or later dying of
mercury poisoning you took the mercury
poisoning my guess is that a hundred
years from now we'll look back at the
chemotherapy treatments and thinks
they're about the same thing as what was
going on wow really yeah and it seems
like cancer you know it's it's very base
is genetic mutations and so people would
say how to software come into this
equation in well I think you have a
story about a retreat where he maybe had
a Eureka moment I'm not sure is a Eureka
moment but at least for me personally it
is so the the reason that the cancer and
that actually lot of biology is is very
hard is that cells are insanely
complicated things that the human genome
has got a little over three billion
bases where a base is one of four
letters and so it's this enormous
complicated thing and it's very very
difficult to understand what that does
and how changes in it which of the
mutations that happen in cancer what
what they do simply by thinking about it
or but by designing experiments to
attack particular things so instead you
really need to use computers to handle
right we have none of the tool to have a
large amounts of data and it's computers
so a couple years ago it was at a
retreat that was being run by david
paterson our third or third panel member
and he had a talk given by David
Haussler who's a professor at UC Santa
Cruz and Taylor Sittler who is a
pathology resident UC San Francisco
talking about gene sequencing which is
the the basis of how you would do these
cancer treatments who'd start by taking
the raw data and understanding what's in
the genome and they were describing how
computationally difficult this problem
was and I was in the lecture listening
to it and I thought well I don't see why
this is so hard I thought of an
algorithm that should have been much
faster and it turns out it was horribly
naive at the time but it was enough to
get me working on the on the project and
building a prototype which got picked up
by some grad students at Berkeley and
then
back to me and has turned into a piece
of software that does the first stage or
nearly the first stage in genome
reassembly which it doesn't say if I
could put them genome together it's
deciding figure out what your genome is
from the data that comes off of a
machine that does sequencing mm-hmm
speaking of sequencing there are a lot
of research you know is associated with
costs in sequencing costs or declining
question is sort of what's the problem
is a thousand dollars for medical tests
didn't seem that unusual well when you
start to sew for cancer you probably
want to do more than thousand dollar
test because you need to have deeper
coverage because all cancer cells are
not like each other around all your
normal healthy cells have the same
genome all your cancer cells if you have
cancer and don't but if you start to do
this on a really wide scale you do it
for lots and lots of people for research
purposes or you start the sequence
everyone it turns out that the cost of
the hardware that does the sequencing
that the actual wet lab machine has been
coming down really quickly but the cost
of the computation to assemble the
output of that into something useful
hasn't been coming down nearly as
quickly and so if you look at those
curves over time it turns out that the
computation very quickly dominates it
already costs hundreds and hundreds of
dollars of compute time to put together
a genome and so attacking that problem
will help bring the cost down to
something much less than a thousand
dollars and make it practical to do
everywhere so let's let's circle back
because you talked about coming up with
the idea for an algorithm at a retreat
and at the time it wasn't quite so talk
to us about where things are now and how
does the algorithm work so the algorithm
off to describe a little bit of a hug
gif cleansing works so the the current
state of the art gene sequencing
machines take the genome that's this
giant three billion base long thing and
split it up into little parts that are
essentially a hundred 100 bases long and
everybody's genome even cancer genomes
are almost exactly the same as everyone
else's the set of changes is fairly
small so what you have to do once you
get these these little chunks of DNA
that are that are a hundred bases long
or 200 bases long now and the Machine
tells you what those bases are you have
to reassemble them it's like putting a
puzzle together with only with a billion
pieces that that over
so you have a reference that's that's
what the generic person looks like and
you take these pieces that came from the
sequencing machine you try to figure out
where they fit best in the reference and
then stated later stages in the
sequencing pipeline will look at say all
the reads that map to one particular
piece of a particular chromosome and try
to decide what's in there so that it
looks for differences between the the
person that you sequence to the tumor
that you sequenced and the reference and
that in turn lets you understand say
what changed in the genes that are
driving the cancer or you know what
makes your your eyes the color they are
or any other genetic thing that you're
trying to understand so at its base it's
a string matching problem if you think
of it as computer scientists which is my
training rather than as a biologist it's
a string matching problem so you have
this giant string of three size three
billion and the others little string of
size 100 and you finally find the place
that it matches the best and the idea
that I had during the lecture was to
just use a hash table which is a sort of
the first computer science class that
you take a data structure that you learn
and it's a way to do very quick exact
lookups so you can you can take you know
if you have say 20 instead of 100 you
can find you can make a hash table that
tells you every place in the human
genome where these 20 bases occur and
then you can use that to try to figure
out where this fits and the reason you
can do this now and you couldn't before
is that the table turns out to be about
40 gigabytes which used to be a lot of
memory and now my laptop has 32 right so
you know it's no longer such a big deal
but that's the the essence of the
algorithm and there's a Chris a
tremendous amount of detail that what
happened in the previous the in the
succeeding two years yeah well which
again you said sort of came from that
retreat of which David was at and David
of course is on the other side of the
computer joining us online David want to
bring you into the conversation too what
have been some of the challenges as
you've seen things so far well I think
the big challenge for all three of us
was to learn biology Leah we were
inspired by the importance of the
problem we got involved we invited David
hustler and Taylor Sittler to the
retreat it that Berkeley sponsored
because we have a big data
called the amp lab and we really needed
a lot of data to be able to drive the
research and so we brought them there
asking if this would be a good
application and then we were caught up
in the you know the human toll of cancer
and so we want to get involved so one of
the things we had to do was you know I
think our I think bill just took a class
I think his prior class was biology was
in high school I think that captured a
lot of us so kind of the question to
make progress could computer scientists
learn enough biology to make a
contribution and that was kind of
research hypothesis we started from and
I'd say two years into this the answer
is yes bill and Robbie and Berkeley
students have made some really great
tools we think the the so-called
puzzle-solving piece called a liner we
think we've got the certainly the
fastest one and just about as accurate
as anyone out there and that came from
computer scientists there's another
thing that they'll talk about at the
faculty summit tomorrow is to be able to
make these breakthroughs to your unique
cancer this so called precision or
personalized medicine we need to see
everybody in the world who's had a
cancer that looks something like yours
and what drugs worked and what drugs
didn't so need to build a giant database
that has this information that would be
extremely helpful to fight cancer and
boy computer scientists could play a big
role there well David you've got a lot
of books behind you I assume some of
them are on biology got to be a smart
guy once you have the patient's genome
sequenced how do you figure out what
parts are responsible for the cancer
well the idea is yeah I think the other
thing to keep in mind here is you know
if there's this really interesting book
that got a lot of involved called the
Emperor of all maladies which is a two
thousand year history of the attempts to
fight cancer so I'd say this genetic
approach is the most promising so far
and it seems most likely to do it but
it's a pretty tough disease so you know
so this is the right next step but you
know beware it may be even more
complicated to be 0
22 to go ahead I think I lost my the
question what was your question talking
about shredding she is shredding the ok
here I'll get you back on track let me
let me let me focus as you are not here
because well we're sitting here in
redmond washington a lot of work is
actually taking place at your lab and
berkeley talk about what's happening
here in this collaborative nature
between you and your team and it's been
a really great collaboration three
microsoft it was actually a bill i still
remember bill asking that question when
Taylor said how long it take and bill
says shouldn't take that long and that
led to all this I think yeah you know we
built in the Berkeley students and
Robbie start building software all along
and just we started comparing to the
others and learned a lot more biology to
try and become as accurate as they were
the repository is another challenge but
there's a lot of non technical
challenges associated with that there's
obviously cure concerned around privacy
but and we also need to get patient
consent we need to figure out that way
do that right now the way cancer studies
are done is every study has its own
consent so that for a researcher to look
at hundreds of thousands of genomes to
see if there's some drug that would work
on one of the others you need permission
from hundreds or thousands of different
permission agencies one per hospital so
there's a bunch of non technical
obstacles i have to get set aside
overcome to be able to collect all this
information together to make a
interesting repository we've also been
interesting kind of classic computer
sciences the way you figure out of
something as betters you would read all
the people working in the field agree on
a benchmark in this field so far has had
very few benchmarks so that's a thing
that we're working on as well is trying
to figure out when somebody else claims
to have a better a liner or what's
called the variant caller what's the
differences between our two genomes how
do you figure that out that's called the
those are called variants we should just
agree on
on a common way to benchmark them that
is agree in the same data sets and
what's good and what's what's better and
what's not better and right now that
doesn't exist so we're trying to step in
and propose those things as well David
one more for you and then I'll open up
to you guys as well the big question is
how close are we to putting this genomic
approach into practice so what are the
obstacles that still need to be overcome
their I mean I we're really close I can
see if there were only technical issues
as theaters to see that bill and Robbie
think given a cloud computing like Azure
and stuff like that the infrastructure
exists that this amount of data isn't
that all that big compared to lots of
other things that are exist in the cloud
so I think and you know can we store
this can we do the analysis economically
boy that all seems you know achievable
technically from our kind of a computer
science perspective there's the societal
issues that are I think greater concern
like is what's more important making
progress on cancer or you know or the
danger of having all the states it
together and that it mayland it's it may
expose the privacy of individuals we
have cancer you know we we've got to
figure out you know what as a society
what the risks and rewards are of
putting one of these things together in
love these other things like patients
can sense that we talked about and then
you know this community of of cancer you
know people cosmos fighting cancer
they're not a particularly you know
computer savvy group by and large and so
they're pretty conservative and not
quite up to date on the technology so
getting them up to data be another
obstacle getting them to a brace cloud
computing for example there's another
obstacle make this happen so I guess I
see the non technical issues is looming
as bigger obstacles than the technical
issues that Robbie and Dylan and people
like us can work on bill robbie david
from his officer of berkeley says he
would be interested to hear what you
guys have to say this is a collaborative
effort he's there you got
here in redmond what do you think how
close are we what's next um I think the
like David said the technical issues are
probably solvable um it's certainly the
case that we can build computer systems
that are more than big enough to handle
the amounts of data that we're talking
about both for individual patients and
also for large sets of patients when
you're doing research studies on we can
absolutely deploy that amount of
computation we honestly spend much more
doing web searches and deciding how to
direct ads at people and more
computation on that than we do try to
cure cancer and so the the ability to do
that is there whether something new will
emerge from the biology and it turns out
to be one level harder than we think you
don't know it too until you try but I'm
optimistic that for our grandchildren
cancer will they'll think of cancer like
we think of smallpox it's something that
you heard about bending everybody yeah
yeah almost like you know that's easily
cured anyway right Ravi you share that
one yeah I mean the other thing I would
add is that this is actually starting
today so there's actually a at sort of
at a limited level there's a set of
cancers that are relatively easy to
diagnose and treat at the molecular
level and we do have a set of targeted
drugs and they're actually about 800
targeted cancer therapies in process at
the FDA and there's a group that we're
talking to at UW Medicine in Seattle
that takes this approach to cancer in
the limited way with the data that we
have now they will sequence a tiny
fraction of the genome they'll look at
it with you know an X sort of an expert
panel of geneticists and then in some
cases they can actually make a treatment
recommendation that will it improve the
prognosis for that patient and so I
think that as we get more data as we get
more computation as the cost of
sequencing goes down this will continue
to improve and it will apply to more
patients and more cancer but I think we
can already see the results today and I
can just see it getting better and
better over the next few min several
years one final thought a bill I know as
David joked about one of the first
things you have to do is all learn
biology that must have been a bit of an
rupt switch for you to focus on that
talk about the unique challenge and
perhaps inspiration from a mid-career
shift so I think there's an old saw
among scientists that you do your best
work on your 20s and spend the rest of
spend the rest of your life teaching
people who will do the interesting work
right and I'm I'm trying to put to the
test at an alternate hypothesis which is
that you do your best work and the the
first 15 years that you're exposed to a
new idea or a new field and then you run
out of ideas so if that's really true
then making a mid-career switch will
allow you to be productive you know
after your hair turns the color that
mine is so it I found it just
tremendously fun to learn about biology
it's a it's a really interesting science
even though people have been working at
it for hundreds of years most of the
real progress in biology has happened in
just the past couple of decades because
the amount of information that it takes
to understand it and the tools that you
need to understand biology have really
only been built you know it's impressive
what Gregor Mendel did in the 19th
century but at was just poking at the
edges now we know what DNA looks like we
know how it works kind of not entirely
we know we know what it does and when I
was an undergraduate the people who went
into biology that people who liked
science and hated math my because there
wasn't much math in biology and this is
really no longer true and so getting an
infusion of people who are numbers
people it is probably good for biology
that's easy for me to say Francis that's
that's I'm a numbers person but at least
the hope is that bringing a little bit
of a different perspective and a little
bit of background and a different set of
lab schools skills right biologists are
taught how to titrate things and to do
experiments with cells and I know how to
deal with computers I'm very good at
that my if you put a test tube in my
hand it would be ugly right well it's
inspiring stuff and certainly for the
sake of my grandchildren you guys keep
it up we really appreciate it appreciate
it David bill Robbie all thank you very
informative discussion great stuff guys
I'm sure I speak for everyone in the
audience when I say I
you the very best in your quest they're
using big data to cure the Big C